ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋อ่าเรา Artist สวัสดี
นักเรียนทำผมเจ๊อ่ะ
ดิคะตอนนี้ครับเราเจอกันนะสำหรับ
บีกินเนอร์ Class อ๋อ
วันนี้วันนี้อ้าวันนี้วันอะไรวันอะไรวัน
นี้วันพุธครับวันนี้วันนี้วันพุธวันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 10 ครับวันนี้
อ้าวันพุธ 10 ค่ายเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับเดือนที่ 5 ยายอนราคาเดือน
ที่ 11 เนาะถูกต้องครับพฤศจิกายนเดือนที่
11 แล้วปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพต
ที่
564 ครับ
2564  64 ชายปีคศเท่าไหร่คะ 5 ปีคศ
2010  21
2021  20 ถูกต้องใช้ครับอ่ะแล้ววันนี้
วันพุธนะคะวันพุธวันเฮ้ยน่ะเราเจอกันเวลา
กี่โมงคะอ้าวเราเจอกันเวลา
15:00 น 20 นาทีครับ 5
15:20 นนาทีค่ะบ้าน 15:20 นอีเนาะได้ใช่
ครับฝ่ายบ่ายแล้วอ่ะบ่าย
3:20 นไปที่ 1 บ่าย 15:00 น 20 นรายหน้า
ร้อนนะคะรอร้อนครับหน้าตอนบ่ายร้อนบ้าน
ครูเอ๋นี่แสงจะไม่มีแล้ว
แต่ร้อนร้อนๆหา
ราคาอะๆวันนี้ร้อนแต่ว่ากูอะติ๊ดเดือนนี้
เดือน 11 ใช่ไหมๆเดือน 11 เดือน 11
ตอนนี้ฝนตกเนี่ยกำลังไปแล้วใช่ไหมคะทราย
ฝนไปแล้วอ่ะฝนไปแล้ว
วันนี้เนี่ยที่ปานครูเอ๋
อากาศร้อนแต่ไม่มากขอร้อนนิดหน่อยใช่ไหม
บ้านบ้านบ้าน้องอาร์ตี้ก็ร้อนหน่อย
หนาวไหมขวัญดิหนาวอ่ะอ่าก็มีหนาวตอนเช้า
ตอนเช้าหนาวหนาวตอนเช้าหนาวไหมคะ
เพราะ
ขอที่บ้านน้องอาร์ตี้ก็หนาวใช่ไหมคะหนาว
ครับที่บ้านน้องอาร์ตี้ก่อนหนาว
เพราะว่าเดือนนี้นักเรียนเดือนที่ 11
เป็นฤดูอะไรคะน้องอาร์ตี้เดือนที่ 11
เป็นฤดูหนาวครับอ้ายอ้าย
[เพลง]
เฮ็ดไทยมีกี่ฤดูคะ
ประเทศไทยมี 3 ฤดูครับอีสาน 3 หรือนาย
ครับสาวฤดูมีฤดูอะไรบ้างคะอ้านี้ครับนี่
ที่ประเทศไทยมี 3 ฤดูครับนี่หนึ่งฤดู
หน้าร้อนขอ
ดูอะไรนะคะจะดูที่ 1 หรือดูอะไรนะคะฤดู
ร้อนครับอ๋อสอนร้อนไม่รู้ที่ไหนเราดูอะไร
คะเมื่อคืนที่สองเป็นฤดูหนาวครับฤดู
ๆหนาวๆใช่ครับดูที่ 3 คะฤดูที่ 3 เป็นฤดู
ฝนดูด่วนๆๆๆ
ครับนะคะอ่ะแต่วันนี้เราเปลี่ยน Number
ได้ไหมคะเพราะว่าเดือนนี้เดือน 11 แล้ว
ให้อันที่ 1 ถึงฤดูหนาวได้ไหมได้ครับจะ
ให้ครับฤดูที่ 1 เป็นฤดูหนาวเล่นดูน่าดู
ร้อนเนาะโอเคฤดูที่ 2 เป็นฤดูร้อนครับอ่า
เปลี่ยน
ฤดูฝนมาดูผลประเภ 555 นะคะเพราะว่าตอนนี้
ฤดูหนาวครูเอ๊ยฟังดูเรียนเปลี่ยน
ไม่ทำแล้ว
ที่รูปมีผู้หญิงอ้าใช่ครับมีผู้หญิงอ่ะ
กำลังกำลังหนาวนะยืนดูดูหน้ามองดูตุ๊กผู้
หญิงดูอะไรคะดูหมอกใช่ไหมค่ะใช่ครับดู
หมอกทรายดูหมอกกรฤดูหนาวเอาใส่หมวกด้วย
เนาะ
ใช่ครับใส่หมวกอ้าเพราะว่าหนาวก็เลยใส่
มั่วนะคะตาหาใส่เสื้อ
ใส่เสื้อคนไทยเรียกว่าเรียกเสื้อชื่ออะไร
กันหนาวขอ
เอาเสื้อกันหนาวใส่เสื้อกันหนาวไม่หนาวหา
เพราะว่าไปเสื้อ 5 ๆมันเสื้อกันหนาวมัน
ใส่แล้วไม่หนาวใช่ไหมๆใช้ค่า
ราคาผู้หญิงก็ยืนนะคะโอประเทศไทยหนาวนัก
เรียน
ที่ไหนหนาวเนี่ยกู Arty พี่เทียเชียงใหม่
ครับเทียงใหม่หนาว
ท้ายครับเชียงใหม่ภาคเหนือหนาว
กรุงเทพหนาวไหมคะ
กรุงเทพฯหนาวนิดหน่อย
นานิดหน่อยตอนเช้าตอนเช้าตอนเช้าหนาวค่ะ
ตอนนี้ตอนบ่ายตอนบ่ายร้อนตอนบ่ายร้อนอะไร
กับอาบังประมาณตี 4 นะ 04:00 นตี
04:00 ทรายขาว 4:00 นนา 4:00 น 5:00  14
หนาวหน้าตอนนี้ตอนตี 4 หนาวนะคะอ่าครับ
แล้วเวลาประเทศไทยหนาวนะโอเคข้างหลังกู
อันตี้มีรูปอะไรอ่ะหาข้างหลังครัวที่จะ
เป็นรูปนี่ครับเป็นรูปน้ำแข็งมีน้ำแข็ง
นี่น้ำแข็งที่ไหนคะอ้าน้ำแข็งอยู่บนใบไม้
นี้ใบไม้มีน้ำแข็งเอกก็มีน้ำแข็งกู Arty
โป้ข้อมีน้ำแข็งน้ำแข็งอยู่ที่ไหนครับ
อยู่ในแก้วแล้วก็มีหลอดกระดูดน้ำแข็งอยู่
ในแก้วนะโอเคแต่อันนี้น้ำแข็งอยู่บนมีใบ
ไม้
เพราะว่าหนาวใช่ไหมคะตายครับเพราะว่าหนาว
หนาวมาเลยมีน้ำแข็งนะคะๆ
ก็ก็คนไทยนะคะนักเรียนน้ำเวลาหนาวแล้วก็
มีน้ำน้ำเราก็มีใบไม้แล้วน้ำมาเกาะน้ำ
แล้วเปลี่ยนเป็นน้ำแข็งๆแห่งหาคนไทยพูดคน
ไทยพูดแม่แค่อ้าใช่คนไทยผู้แม่คันนี้ไง
อ่ะแม่คะนิ้งบนใบไม้
สาขาครับฤดูหนาวคู่อาติ๊ดชอบครับฤดูหนาว
ไหมคะ 5 ขวดติดฮอบฤดูหนาวค่ะชอบฤดูหนาว
เพราะว่าฤดูหนาวครัวตีได้ไปเที่ยวอ่าชาย
ครับแม่ไม่แอบดูนักเรียนชอบฤดูหนาวไหม
เนาะ
ๆครับผู้เหวกูอ่ะหมีชอบไหมกูเห็นชอบดู
หนาวไหมขอไม่ชอบเพราะว่าครูเอ๋ทันอ๋ออ๋อ
ฤดูหนาวคันเหรอครับคันคันคู๋ต้องมีโลชั่น
แล้วก็ขออาถ้าไม่คันทาโลชั่นไม่คันใช่
โอเคแล้วครูอาตี้ปูอัดที่บอกว่ากู Arty
ชอบฤดูหนาวครับคิดไปเที่ยว
ไปเที่ยวที่ไหนคะน่ากลัวตี้ไปเที่ยว
ไปเที่ยวที่ประเทศไทยนี้ครับนางเอกคิด
ชื่อนะ 5 ที่ไหนครับแต่ปีไหนครับที่ไหน
อ่ะมีกินไหมคะภาคเหนือภาคอีสานภาคเหนือ
ครับข้างเหนือภูชี้ฟ้า
ห้าใช่ครับภูชี้ฟ้าอยู่บนภูเขาอยู่บนครู
โอ๋อ่ะชื่อ
ภูชี้ฟ้า
ใช่ครับอ่านี่ค่าที่รูปนี้มีหน้าในรูปนี้
มีหมอกนี่ตรงนี้มีหมอกค่าข้าวมีบอกเยอะ
เลยตอนเช้าใช่ครับหมอกสีอะไรคะครูอัตตีน
อ่ะหมอกสีขาว
r54 อันนี้สีขาวชายครับบอกสู้สาวทิพย์
สู้สีขาวบอกสีขาว
k5 แล้วก็มีพระค่ะคิดมั้ยคะใช่นี่ครับมี
พระอาทิตย์หน้า
มีพระอาทิตย์อยู่ตรงนี้อ่าพระอาทิตย์ตอน
เช้าตอนเช้าพล่าทิพย์ 4 ส้ม
สีหน้าใส่ครับสีส้มนะส้มได้สีอานี่ครับ
ถูกต้องใช่ครับอ่าโอเคมีปากกาสีส้ม
ฮ่าๆสีส้มสีแดง
อา
ๆคล้ายๆกันใต้อ่าโอเค
อาทิตย์สีส้มแล้วก็มีอะไรอยู่คนคะมีมาก
ครับเป็นฟ้าให้เป็นท้องฟ้าใส่ครับเรายืน
อยู่ตรงนี้ถ้าแล้วเราก็ชี้
ทีที่ไปที่ท้องฟ้าอ่า
ก็ได้ครับอย่างนี้หน้า
เด็กช่องเด็กอันนี้สีนิ้วครับอ่า
ชี้ฟ้าโอเคคนไม่โอเคนะคะๆใจครับเราเรียก
ว่าภูชี้ฟ้าแดงข้าก็มีเมฆด้วยตรงไหนเป็น
ไม่ได้คะมีเมฆอยู่ตรงนี้ครับนี่มีเมฆมี
เมฆตรงนี้อ้ามีเมฆเยอะเลยใช่ครับ
แล้วก็มีตอนย่าเนาะตอนย่าตายายมีต้นหญ้า
สีเขียวเขียวอยู่ตรงนี้ใช้ขาน
ครูอตี้คิดครับจะไป
ไปเที่ยวที่ภูชี้ฟ้าใช่ไหมคะอ่ะใช่ครับ
ครัวติอยากไปเที่ยวที่มาดูทีฟ้า
ฝันอยากไปเที่ยวที่พูดๆครูเอ๋เอ๋อยากไป
ไหมครับ
ฮ่าๆๆฮ่าๆๆๆไหม
อยากหรือได้อยากดูเขาใช่ไหม
เดินขึ้นภูเขามีสิทธิ์หน่อย
นิดหน่อยกี่เมตรโห
เฮ้อไม่ไกลไม่ไกลประมาณ 2 กิโลเมตรอ่ะไม่
ไปเดินขึ้นภูเขา
ก็เดินแบบนี้เดินเดินเดิน
Shopping  Mall หาโอเคต้องเดินแบบนี้
เดินได้โอเคโอเคใช่ไหมเป็ดเดินขึ้นภูเขา
มีแต่ถ้าเดินแบบนี้
เดิน
ไม่ไหว
ขอโทษค่ะครูเอ๋อายุ 53 ขอ
หัวเข่า
ผัวเก่ายังนักข่าวปวดเข่าไม่โอเค
หัวเข่าให้ดีที
เดินลงไม่โอเคอ๋อ
กูๆเป็นไรเดี๋ยวครูเองขึ้นโอเค
ใช่ๆเด็กๆแข็งแรงวิ่งขึ้นวิ่งขึ้นภูเขา
ได้ฮ่าๆแล้วก็วิ่งลงภูเขาก็ได้
วิ่งลงกูเขาไม่ดีที่น่าไว้ดีๆครับอันขอ
ไฟล์จากล้มผมใช่ครับ / ล้มลงมาครูแพทตี้
ก็คิดครับใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็อยากจะไปภูชายวัน
นี้อยากไปภูชี้ฟ้าตอนฤดูหนาวอ้าวสายๆกัน
หนาวนะใช่ครับใส่เสื้อกันหนาวด้วยใส่หมวก
ใส่หมวกด้วยทรายกี่คน 1 คน 2 คน 3 คน 4
คน 5 ตัวตีไป 4 คนไป 4 คนมีครูขี้อะไรคะ
อ้าใช่ครับไปกับครอบครัว
บ้านของครัวที่บ้านของครัวตี้มี 4 คนมี
ใครบ้างคะมีพ่อครัวตี้เป็นพ่อ
ว่าโอเคอ้าวาดอย่ากลัวตี้ว่าดีๆก่อนก็ได้
ค่าได้ครับ
หาผัวตี้เป็นพ่อ
เป็นพ่อ
กูอัดตีแล้วก็แต่งงาน
แต่งงานแล้วควรตี้ก็มีมีขยะหน้าภรรยาครับ
มันไปยาได้ค่าพญาทั้งใส่กระโปรงจะเป็นนะ
คะ
ครับผมได้ครับผมแฟนผู้หญิง
ที่ก็มีลูกนะมีลูกด้วยครัวตี้มีลูกคะมี
ลูก 2 คนครับ
มีลูกเป็นผู้ชาย 2 คนโค่น
ใต้ใช่ครับเนอะไปด้วยกันก็ไปยังไงคะขับรถ
เออขับรถไปกวนตีนขับรถไปภูอุ้ยหมีป๋าได้
ครับหน้าหนาวขับรถแล้วก็ครอบครัวจะและราย
เขาว่าที่รถแล้วก็ขับรถฮงอเหมือนๆขับรถไป
ปิคนิคเลยนะเออขับไปเที่ยวใช่ครับไป
เที่ยวที่กูชิมะตัวตีไปไปตอนหน้าหนาวควร
ที่ไปกางเต็นท์การเต้นให้มีรถคะนี้นี่
คอร์ด E ไปกางเต็นท์มีเขาแปลกเป็นๆๆเหงา
หน้ามีเจาะไม้สีชมพูด้วย 5 ทรายครับมีดอก
ไม้สีชมพูที่หากเหนือตอนหน้าหนาวมีดอกไม้
สีชมพู
สวยสวยสวยมากๆครับตีท่อคู่อะติ๊กกาง
เต้นท์มีข่าวเป็นคะอ่ะหัวหน้ากางเต้นท์มี
สองบี 1 เต้นอ้ามีหนึ่งเต้นอยู่ตรงนี้
เต้นใหญ่และมีเต็นท์เล็กอยู่ตรงนี้น้าซ่า
เย็นนะคะมีสองเต็นท์อยู่ใกล้กันนะสอง Benz
ครูเอกคิดนะกูอันตี้มันหนาว 4 คนนอนด้วย
กันหนึ่งเป็นโอเค
ฮ่าๆดีครับนอนด้วยกันครับเออนอนด้วยกัน 4
คนใน 1 เต็นท์ดีกว่านะคะดีกว่ากว่าครับดี
กว่า
ขอครู Arty แล้วก็นอนที่เป็น
ๆได้กลัวที่ชอบนอนที่เต็นท์นะ
ดีมาก
นะครับเต้น 5 ชอบนอนเต็นท์เหมือนกันแต่
ถ้าไม่ชอบ
Top ทำเต้นอ๋อไม่ชอบไม่ชอบทำเต็นท์แบบ
นี้ใช่ไหมครับครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบทำกูไอ้ชอบนอน
ไม่ชอบธรรมว่าโอเค
ๆ
หือก็จะไปกางเต็นท์ที่ภูชี้ฟ้านะคะเวลา
เราจะเท่ห์กูอะตี้อัพเวลาหน้าหนาวเนี่ย
อุณหภูมิ
กี่องศาเซลเซียสคะที่อ้อ
ตอนหน้าหนาวที่ภูชี้ฟ้าอุณหภูมิก็จะ
อุณหภูมิประมาณ
ตอนหน้าหนาวประมาณประมาณ
10 องศาครับ 10 องศาเซลเซียสหยิบองศา
เซลเซียลหน้าเป็นเซลเซียสอันนี้เลี๊ยบเรา
เรียกว่าอะไรนะ
มีสติที่มานี้จะไม่ครับอันนี้
คนไทยเรียก
เทอร์โมมิเตอร์คนไทยนะเธอมากเตอร์ฮ่าๆ
โมมิเตอร์ฮ่าๆก็ใช้เช็คอากาศเนาะว่าใช่
เอาสาเซลเซียส
ใช่ประมาณ
15 ราคาคุณอาสาอุ่นหภูมิพูดอย่าอะไรนะ
พูดว่าอะไรนะคุณหน้าอุ่นหภูมิอ้า
อุณหภูมิ 10 องศาใส่ครับ 10 องศาสกุลหน้า
หนาวไหมหนาว kuai ขอ 30
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ 30 องศาไหมครับอ่ะอัน
นี้หรอตอนนี้พี่ต้องได้ไหมบ้านครูเอ๋กี่
องศาครับโทรศัพท์กู SX ได้ไหม
ไม่แน่ใจเออ
สามสิบสองค่ะ
32 อ่ะ 32 ไม่หนาว 32 ร้อน
92 องศาเซลเซียสอ้า 32 องศา
เมื่อไหร่สบาย 32 สบายๆใช่มั้ยโอเคครับ
อ่ะกูเอ๋เอ๋เดี๋ยวตอนนี้เราไปเที่ยวหน้า
หนาวแล้วเราไปเจอฤดูหนาวแล้วเดี๋ยวเราไป
ฤดูอะไรกันต่อครับอ๋อรึดูแลคือฤดูหนาวใน
ประเทศไทยมีสามฤดูตอนนี้ดูหนาวครู Arty
ก็คิดใช่ไหมเดี๋ยวอ่ะเดือน 11 เดือน 12
เนี่ย of วิ่งดิก็ไปไป
เสือภูเขาภูชี้ฟ้าๆๆพรหนาวเสร็จนักเรียน
ร้อน
ร้อนๆครับหนาวแล้วก็ร้อนเจฤดูร้อนนะฮะอ่า
ต่อไปเราไปฤดูร้อนกันโอเคฤดูที่
ฤดูที่ 2 ฤดูร้อนมาฮาแล้วร้อนไหมครับร้อน
ๆๆๆ
คู๋ท่อบฤดูร้อนไหมครับชอบค่ะอ๋อ
ขวดที่
ไปตีชอบนิดหน่อยฤดูร้อยชอบฤดูร้อนเพราะ
ว่าเพราะว่าชอบกินเหรอครับมีมีมีมีอาหาร
มากๆอ๋อมีอาหารมากฤดูร้อนใช่ไหมครับมีธ.ค
และผลไม้มากผลไม้มากฤดูร้อยนะมีทุเรียน
ด้วยนะครับกลัวตี้ก็ชอบกูเอมีรูปทุเรียน
มั้ยเนี่ยจะน้อมีไหมครับกูเองว่าเป็นไงคะ
สีเขียวน้อง
ทุเรียน
เหมือนไหมอ่ะ
โอเคใช่ครับนี่ทุเรียนสีเขียวมีเออ
ข้างในสีเหลืองเนาะ
ชาย
ทุเรียนข้างในสีเหลือง
ข้างนอกสีเขียวนะคะกูเอกก็กินทุเรียน
กินทุเรียนว้าวอ้ามีฤดูร้อนๆหน้าร้อนก็
เลยชอบแล้วก็เวลารอสต้องไปทะเล
ว้าวไปทะเลครัวตี้ก็ชอบไปทะเลฤดูร้อน
เหมือนกันเพื่อนซ้ายครับทะเลไหมคะถ้ามี
รูปทะเลหาทะเลสวยสวยฤดูร้อนได้หาย
อันนี้ที่ที่ไหนหัวหินครับอ๋อหัวหิน r-one
หินสวยหินหน้าสวยค่ะ
ทะเลมีมีอะไรอร่อยบ้างครับมีมีทรายมีช้าง
อ่าใช่ครับนี่ตรงนี้เป็นทรายค่ะนี่อายมี
ทรายนะคะบ้างบางที่พูดชายหาดอ่ะนะฮะทราย
สายทั้งหมดคนไทยพูดชายหาดและนะครับแล้วก็
มีอีกขึ้นหน่อยขื้นชื่อหน้าคืนอยู่ตรงนี้
ครับอันนี้คืนนะคะ
ใต้อันนี้คลื่นอ่ะโอเคนี่คือคืนค่ะเราก็
มีน้ำทะเล
หาน้ำทะเลอยู่ตรงนี้อ้านี่น้ำทะเล
มีเรือ
อ๋อมีเรืออยู่นี่ครับคือเสื้ออยู่ในทะเล
แล้วก็มีท้องฟ้าอ่าใช่ครับมีท้องฟ้านี่
เป็นท้องฟ้าแล้วก็มีแรงด้วยมีแมกด้วยครับ
มีเป็นเมฆอ่ะอ่ะเมฆของฟ้า
น้ำทะเลใช่ๆๆเราไปว่ายน้ำทะเลตอนฤดูร้อนๆ
ครับกินได้ไหมคะมีเสน่ห์น้ำทะเลกินไม่ได้
กินไม่ได้พี่เอ๋แพ้กินน่ะทะเลไหมเค้า
กิน
ไม่กินน้ำทะเลกินไม่ได้ไม่กินกินนะคะโอ๊ย
กูอันตี้คู๋รอ
หาฤดูหนาวไป
อ่าฤดูหนาวไปร้อนมากูเองให้ทะเล
โอเค
ก็ก็เดี๋ยวพอฤดูหนาวไปก็จะได้ไป
ว่ายน้ำน่าว่ายน้ำที่ทะเลๆหรือไม่ก็ไป
อ้าไปนอนนอนอาบแดดอาบหน้าที่ทะเลมีมีมีมี
วันอาทิตย์ได้ไหมอ่ะแล้วก็มีแดดเหรอเออ
ใต้มีแดดส่องแสงออกมานะมีแดก
หาทรายครับและก็นอนตรงนี้อาบแดดอยากไป
โอเคอ่า
เห็นแล้วอยากไปทะเลอยากไปเด้กูเองครับ
แล้วถ้าต่อฤดูหนาวแล้วฤดูร้อนแล้วแล้วมี
ฤดูอะไรอีกนะครับโดยที่ 3 ฤดูฝนอ๋ออ๋อ
เป็นฤดูฝนไส้ไหมครับนี่นี่ก็คือฝนอาอะ
แล้ว
เอ๋ก็ชอบฤดูฝนเหรอครับชอบดูสนชอบฤดูร้อน
ชอบฤดูฝนชอบฟังเวลาอ๋อ
ขอฝนตกฝนตกมีเสียงเสียงฝนตก
รอบเวลาฝนตกเสร็จแล้วจะมีเสียงตอบออกโอ๊ะ
ๆ
เสียงเสียงตัวอะไรครับกบค่ะขอ
เสียงกบดูฮ่วยตอนฝนตกก็ไหมครับเดี๋ยวกลัว
ตี้วาดรูปอบก็ได้ไหมตอบเป็นหนึ่งนี้มีข้อ
เป็นยังไงอ้านี่กรอบ
อ้าใช่ไหมครับขอบมีตาอยู่แบบนี้กลัวตีวาด
เหมือนไว้เป็นกบมั้ย
กูอีกว่าเหมือนไหมฮะเหมือนไหม
กบอะไรก็เหมือนค่ะ
ก็มีลิ้นยาวๆถึงจะเข้ายาวกินแมลงฮ่าๆๆแต่
เหมือนหัวเต้ออกน้องอบอุ่น 81 นี้ใช่ไหม
ถ้า
โอเค
แล้วจะดูฝนมีอะไรอีกคะฤดูฝนล่ะครับ
กลัวนี่ก็ชอบฤดูฝนเดี๋ยวพี่ S  R ขวด
แต่ขวดอี้เวลาออกไปข้างนอกออกไปข้างนอก
ตอนที่ฝนตกตีก็ต้องใส่ใส่เสื้อเสื้อกันฝน
อ๋อถ้าถ้าปะฤดูหนาวใส่เสื้อกันหนาวๆเขา
ใส่เสื้อกันฝนตายอ่านี่แฟนใครคะสีแดงสี
แดงสีแดงคือร่มทำอร่อยร่อม
Rom เกาะกันฝนค่าหน้านี่อ่าใส่เสื้อใส่
ซื้อเครื่องคันฝน
ใส่อะไร
ดูร้อน
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ร้อนร้อนๆไหมใส่ใส่เสื้อสั้นๆใส่เสื้อตัว
เล็กๆไม่เอาอ่ะโอเคครับ
ครูอาร์ทตี้มีเสื้อกันฝนที่บ้านไหมคะหน้า
ที่บ้านครัวที่มีเสื้อกันฝนครับมีเสื้อ
กันฝนแล้วก็มีร่มด้วยมีร้องด้วยนะร่มด้วย
ใช่ครับค่ะดีค่ะดีหรือ
on ฝนตกตอนฝนตกมีเสียงดังเรียงเปียงอ่ะ
กูเอ๋เคยได้ยินไหมครับเสียงดังตอนฝนตก
ค่ายได้ครับฟ้าผ่าสร้างโน้ทาให้อ๊อดฝนตก
จะมีฝาผ่าแบบแต่ถ้ามัน
อันนี้ฟ้าแลบใช่ไหมหาป๊าลำไส้ครับเมียแสง
สว่างมีแสงสว่างไม่มีเสียงมาให้มีเสียง
อ่ะเป็นฟ้าแลบฟ้าแลบแต่ถ้าเลี่ยงเนี่ยฟ้า
ใช่ๆๆฮ่าๆๆฮ่า
[เพลง]
แบบนี้ฟ้าร้องฟ้าร้องไห้ฟ้าร้องไห้
ปลาร้องได้เขากลัวไหมคะ R ครัวตี้ไม่กลัว
ครับไม่กลัวครูเอ๋แล้วครับกูเอกกลัวมั้ย
ถ้ากลัวฟ้าร้องฉันกลัวฟ้าขั้น
คืนไม่กลัวจะทับนะอย่าตกใจอ๋อตกใจฝาผ่า
คุย
เคยมีเมื่อก่อนมีที่
อพาร์ทเม้นท์ครับอพาร์ทเม้นท์แล้วเอาบัตร
เม้นฝนตกแล้วก็
เลี่ยงฟ้าผ่าเปรี้ยงๆๆโหน้ำครั้ง
3 ชั่วโมงโอ้โหโห pass นี่กูเองฟ้า
ผ่า 3 ชั่วโมงโอ้โห
คืออพาร์ทเม้นต์ครูเอกตรงนี้ก็เถอะนะอ่า
อพาร์ทเม้นท์แล้วก็
อ้ะ Apartment ครูเอ๋นี่แล้วก็มีที่นี่
ข้างบนน่ะฟ้าผ่า
มาที่นี้ค่ะอ๋อ
3 ชั่วโมงพี่ก็นอนไม่ได้นอนไม่หลับ
เสียงดังเสียงดังนะเสียงฟ้าผ่าเสียงดังอา
ก็เลยกลัว
อะไรกลัวฟ้าผ่าแต่แต่แต่ฟ้าร้องโอเคอ๋อ
โอเคค่ะฟ้าร้องไม่กลัวกลัวฟ้าผ่า
โทรหาเคยเห็นหงอ
แล้วเวลาฝนตกแล้วฟ้าผ่าแล้วข้าก็จะมีมี
อันนี้ครับนี่
ฮ่าๆนี่เองที่
รุ้งรุ้งได้มีรุ้งอาอันไหนคะรุ้งอันไหน
หลวงคืออันนี้ครับมีมีรุ้งท้ายครับอ่า
รุ้งมี
มีหลายสีรุ้งมีสีอะไรบ้างครับเดี๋ยวนะจะ
มีสีอะไรบ้างหลงจักนะคะๆ
สอน
นี่
ครบไหมมีกี่สีรุ้งมีกี่สีมิดเจ็ดสีอ่ะแต่
กูอาทิตย์ที่ 1  4 คิดว่ารุ้งมี 7 สี
อ้าวก็จะมีจะมีสีอะไรบ้างครับสีแดง
หามีสีแดงสีส้ม
ใช่ป่ะครับฮ่าๆเหลือง
สีเขียวๆเดี๋ยวกลัวที่บอกให้ใหม่สีรุ้งจะ
เป็นม่วงครามน้ำเงินเขียวเหลืองแสดแดง
จะสนคนคงๆจะ
เอาใหม่อะไรนะเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้หาสีม่วงก่อน
อ่ะสีม่วงมีสมัยนี้สีม่วงโอเคสีม่วง
อันนี้ไปสีม่วงมะม่วงแล้วก็ครามสีคราวอ่ะ
อันนี้ดูเป็นพราหมณ์เลยนะเนี่ยอีกครามา
ใส่ครับพวกเกม
แล้วก็สีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินไม่มีมีสีฟ้า
น้ำเงินนี่อ่ะแล้วก็สีเขียวสีเขียวมี
สีเขียวอ้าแล้วก็สีเหลืองสีเหลืองมีค่ะ
ได้ครับแล้วก็สีแสดก็คือสีส้มสีส้มอ่าไอ้
ส้มๆครับแล้วก็สีแดงเนอะ
ไงครับมี 7 สีสีหน้านะครับป่าวสวยงาม 07
สีสวยงามเลียได้ไหมลูก
หน้ารุ้งคนไทยคนไทยไม่ที่ให้ที่ห้ามสี
ก็วันนี้น้องอ๋อหน้าฝนฝนตกเสร็จแล้วก็มี
รุ้งกินนางหน้า
สวยอะไรครับวันนี้วันนี้เราเรียนไปอาร์ม
ฤดูมีฤดูอะไรบ้างครับอ่าฤดู
ฤดูหนาวค่ะอ้าฤดูหนาวใช่ครับเออไม่ดูอะไร
นะคะฤดูที่ 2 ครับนี่ฤดู
ร้อนครับฤดูร้อนนะโอเคแล้วก็ฤดูฤดูที่ 3
ไม่โทรหาดูที่สามอ้าวดูที่สามฤดูถ้าฝน
ซ้ายครับคนที่ชอบฝนฮ่าๆๆผู้เห็นชอบฤดูฝน
แล้วก็ฤดูร้อนอ่าตัวตีจำได้ขวดที่ท่อบทุก
ฤดู
kuai ไม่ให้ดูหนาวไม่ชอบฤดูหนาวชอบนะคะ
อ้าก็ประเทศไทยมี 3 ฤดูนะคะซ้ายครับดูนัก
เรียนมีกี่ฤดูเนาะขอนักเรียนมีกี่ฤดูครับ
นักเรียนคอมเม้นนะพิมพ์คอมเม้นท์บอกครู
Arty บอกพี่เอ๋แล้วนะคะว่างอเมริกามีกี่
ฤดู
ยุโรปมีกี่ฤดู
ญี่ปุ่นมีกี่ฤดูไต้หวันมีกี่ฤดูอินเดียมี
กี่ฤดู
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
แคนาดามีกี่ฤดูนี้นะคะประเทศไทยมี 3 ฤดู
อ่ะพิมพ์คอมเม้นมาครับคอมเม้นนะฉันคน
แคนาดามี 2  3  2  3  4 ฤดูหนาวบอกครูอัน
นี้ก็บอกไปด้วยนะคะแม่นก็แล้วใช่ไหมคะขอ
อันที่ใต้หมดเวลาแล้วหยุดเวลาแล้วอ้อนๆๆ
งั้นสองคนต้องไปแล้วนะคะบ๊ายบายแจ้งครับ
หน้าเจอกันใหม่สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดี
ครับพี่เอ๋เอ๋ครับผมบ๊ายบายน